Welcome back everyone it's charlie a lot of
you been asking me to do a new walking dead video
since this is going to be the final season
in there been several trailers for the first
batch of episodes this is getting my walking
dead season 11 refresher video AMC released
season 11 episode 1 a week early on their
streaming bundle AMC+ so if you haven't seen it yet
Be sure to check it out there service AMC+
is available on all platforms and devices.
However you watch your TV show should be good
to go up a link for that stuff in the description
below the boat is there is that you can watch
the full episode one week early before they
are on television they been doing this for
the past few years on a Thursday, so some
of you probably already known about it.
The difference this year.
Is this the first time AMC+ is releasing each
episode.
The Sunday before airs on television.
If you really like the bonus content that
they been doing for the final season they
been doing a bunch of special bonus episodes,
interviews and all that for the main characters
that they been releasing each week they're
trying to go all out.
Just because it is the last season of the
main show as the dam posting this video AMC+
already has the walking dead origins episodes
featuring Daryl Maggie Negan and Carol also
worked in a bunch of new preview footage from
future episodes into those bonus episodes as well
But the real big thing for this final season
for season 11 is that Maggie is back for pretty
much the entire season and their doing the
Commonwealth storyline from the comics.
Finally, which is what that for commercial
in the trailers all about hello I'm Lance
Hornsby welcome to the Commonwealth I love
the whole VHS vibe that they get to that.
Like that's a take they just pass around make
everybody watch whenever they bring them to
the Commonwealth, so just to explain what's
going on with the Commonwealth because are
such a big group the like the next main antagonists
in the series.
They introduce the Commonwealth during season
10 this past year.
They started with Eugene trying to figure
out where Stephanie was from because they
knew that she was from another big community
like Alexandria hilltop Oceanside, but she
always refused to answer any of his questions
about where she was actually from so just
like Eugene does he just kept plugging away
until she eventually caved in revealed that
she was from a community in Charleston West
Virginia which is where the TV show version
of the Commonwealth is located.
But at that time when she was revealing that
none of the characters had use the name Commonwealth
yet nobody was calling it that the first time
that they actually tease them officially on
screen was during season 10 episode 16 a certain
doom when Eugene's group was trying to find
Stephanie's group Wanda being ambushed by
the Commonwealth soldiers in their full storm
trooper looking Walker riot gear all hardcore
the soldiers trying to capture Eugene's group
are all you really learn about them until
season 11 no coincidence that was also the
episode where Maggie came back to the show
with a much larger baby Herschel got a little
bit bigger and the time jump is all that drama
between her and Negan that they still have
to pay off during season 11 who is, since
now come back to Alexandria and tried to help
them rebuild but the big difference between
the Commonwealth and the other settlements
that we've seen on the show so far across
the many many seasons.
Like Alexandria is the Commonwealth is like
a fully functioning state made up of a bunch
of smaller communities is not any 1 Single
place the name Commonwealth is actually a
reference to the collective group of communities
that have banded together in a more organized
form of governance in the apocalypse way more
organized than the alliances that we've seen
previously on the show.
Like when Alexandrian hilltop would team up.
All told, there's about 50,000 people that
call themselves a member of the Commonwealth
between all the different pockets of communities
even have a sports arena concerts with musicians
like they have a thriving cultural arts scene.
Despite the apocalypse like you see during
that intro video that they give.
Like Buckham, the Commonwealth it actually
looks like just a regular community where
you might go live before the apocalypse happened
even have a railroad that they're building
between the different communities to speed
up transportation and as you saw during season
10 with that big teaser.
They even have a fully equipped hardcore fully
functional Army the like the most legit main
group that the characters on the show have
ever encountered in the series.
Their leaders a woman named Pamela Milton
her title is Govenor of the Commonwealth will
meet her during season 11 the Lance Hornsby
character the you see in the trailer is just
one of the higher ranking members underneath
Pamela the person you're seeing in the red
Commonwealth armor is Michael James Shaw,
he's playing Mercer he is hardcore.
I want to get into spoilers for his character.
But he's a really big deal during season 11
what's different about their society, though
the way they organize themselves as they have
this neo-feudal system differentiated by higher
classes and lower-class people based on what
everyone's jobs were before the apocalypse
like all the upper-class people and their
society are the business professionals from
for the apocalypse politicians, doctors, the
lower-class of their society is made up mostly
of the people with blue-collar jobs from before
the apocalypse like general tradesmen like
repairman grocers, farmers people like that.
But the Commonwealth isn't meant to be this
perfect place.
As you can imagine.
Like they have the same types of internal
issues that any large society has when they're
stratified with an extremely wealthy upper-class
and extremely poor, lower-class with the whole
idea is that the Commonwealth is self like
this nationstate made up of smaller communities
continues to take in other small communities
growing larger and larger, so the ideas that
unless something just completely goes off
the rails, which it often does.
People believe that the Commonwealth might
eventually be the permanent replacement for
the former United States like structurally
and governmentally like a totally new type
of nation just laid on top of what used to
be the United States.
Maggie is a huge part of the Commonwealth
storyline.
So that's one of the reasons why Lauren Cohan
came back for so many episodes during season
11 if you haven't read it.
The comic book series ended a while ago's
you cannot she go read that right now.
But the TV show isn't really doing the comic
book storyline the exact same way.
Like Daryl for example 1 of the biggest characters
on the show is not a comic book character
Carol Peletier another good example huge character
on the show radically different from comic
book Carol some of the comic book stuff from
the Commonwealth will seem familiar and there
always Easter eggs with the storylines they
try to include on the TV show episodes.
As of right now they confirm Rick Grimes is
still alive.
Even though his whereabouts are still unknown
they plan on covering what happened to him
after season nine during the walking dead
movies.
They're still working on right now I don't
have any information about those, but they
have said that they're still working on them
in early theory I wouldn't be surprised if
Andrew Lincoln makes another appearance on
the main show at least by the very last episode
season 11 has a total of 24 episode.
So it is a supersize season many the actual
series finale.
The very last episode of the walking dead
won't air till next year if you do have any
big questions about season 11 or what's going
on with any of the characters just right them
below in the comments and I'll try to address
them.
Links for the new episodes on AMC+ are down
in the description below.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you in the next video!